over the last two weeks it's been an
emotional rollercoaster for everybody
and the world has come together in
protests and I just want to ask you
first thing first how are you doing
mentally and spiritually at this point
for me obviously this is taking a toll
on our mental health and emotional
health to be honest I we're getting
there
it's gonna take a long time but I think
with the voice of you know society right
now helping us along the way
that's um we can get through this how
has your journey been to where you are
at this point you guys are a force in
the designing world there's more than
enough energy and time for me to help
others to come up on this and that's why
help black designers Academy I made that
so there's no excuses you can come and
see black excellence every day and
remind yourself that we exist I would
say the store owners to look at your
shelf and then look at yourself and that
or why there's not more black
representation on that self especially
either because maybe you find it inside
that you didn't want to or there it
didn't it didn't apply to the
demographic that you're selling to or
maybe because you didn't look deep
enough and or whether you want it or not
change is coming and whether it's
because of a good thing or bad thing
maybe accountability for is that that's
for sure I made it quite clear that my
publication is going to hold you know
black women and black men as a part of
the spreads we need to flip the
hierarchy you know we need to see more
black editors we need to see more
qualified black editors and fashion
directors and top models and TV hosts
and all of that because through that
lens then the younger generations will
be able to see that you know race as a
whole is equal I think our lives have
been so trivialized for many of us of
color and who are black that you know
this time it's all about change and I
think society has jumped on this I don't
want to call it a bandwagon because it
shouldn't be called a bandwagon but we
really need to continue to shout and
scream if we don't I will be brush under
the rug
yet again and I think you need to have
some happening we're all parents here
having that conversation and you will
have to have that conversation in the
future with them how would you explain
how they're going to be perceived in the
world it's a little bit emotional for me
because um my kids are mixed and I know
100% that my son and my daughter will
identify it with being black and I'm so
worried to start the conversation with
him at this because he's only five years
old at the same time I'm battling with
myself to say it doesn't matter he's
still going to be a black man and the
conversation must be had there and it's
gonna break my heart because I fear for
his life he's going to know because I'm
gonna teach him that unfortunately
people see us that way and um I know
he's gonna own it and I know he's gonna
be a good person
he won't judge people like how White's
judge blacks he will see it for what it
is and if he feels that he is being
racially profiled you'll be able to
recognize that because I will teach him
those things but it's gonna be a tough
conversation to have and it's been a
very vulnerable conversation because I
would hate to taint his world with
something that could be so cruel to
erase
[Music]